we made tap handles for budweiser goose
island miller light you know i think
this is a first with an actual snow
globe on a tap handle
yeehaw pale ale i like this one because
it's just a big awesome looking tap
panel
stegall prescott and central waters to
name a few i'm mark steinhardt general
manager of ajs tap handles i definitely
would try that beer
so a guy walks into a bar and the first
thing he does if it's me i look
what's on tap certainly
the unique tap handles pique your
interest and might push you to try that
beer
i like this tap handle because i'm a
road biker
we're located in random lake wisconsin
which is about 45 minutes north of
milwaukee even though wisconsin is a
rural state we produce tap handles for
the mega breweries on down to the
smallest micro brew
[Music]
we believe we're the largest domestic
producer of tap handles here in the u.s
we ship out approximately a half a
million tap handles each year we can
produce the tap handle from start to
finish this is a very detailed tap
handle and i would guess takes about an
hour to hand paint all the detail on it
companies do try to
have the most eye-catching most unique
tap handle in the bar and it is a cross
between art and manufacturing
we always say our cap handle will sell
your first beer and your beer will sell
the rest
[Music]
you